aoc has suffered
maybe the worst sort of attack
imaginable
you could never imagine this this kind
of thing happening to a member of
congress
she deserves our support she deserves
our sympathy a fellow politician
allegedly called aoc
a mean name she'll explain it to you in
her histrionic
house floor address i was walking up the
steps of the capitol when
representative yoho suddenly turned a
corner
um and he was accompanied by
representative roger williams
and it costed me on the steps right here
in front of our nation's capital
i was minding my own business walking up
on the steps
and representative yoho put his finger
in my face
he called me disgusting he called me
crazy he called me out of my mind
and he called me dangerous i took a few
steps
ahead and i walked inside and cast my
vote
i walked back out and there were
reporters
in the front of the capitol and in front
of reporters representative yoho called
me
and i quote
the horror the horror a politician
called another
politician an insulting name never
happened
before and aoc who regularly compares
donald trump to hitler
is very very upset about that what is
most nauseating here is not even the
histrionics
it is the self-obsession and you see
this kind of self-obsession
from a lot of fake martyrs a lot of
make-believe martyrs
who tend to inflict a lot more harm on
other people
but a lot more other people in a bad
situation
than they find themselves we'll get into
all of it i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show
[Music]
terrible i hope she's okay i hope she's
surviving this you know the strong woman
who's taking over washington i hope
she's surviving
being called a mean name allegedly
allegedly the guy who
she accuses of doing this by the way
completely denies it we will get into
that first though
the best comment that we saw on
thursday's show
was on the youtubes and it described
dr fauci's short baseball career no
accuracy and too far to the left
lol very accurate description and we
will get into fouchy too
also i would like to know your thoughts
today as the sports teams
begin to open back up if your favorite
team takes a knee
how will you respond will you tolerate
that will you go along with that or not
also got to thank our friends over at
paint your life you know i love artwork
i've tried my own hand at painting turns
out it's much harder than
than you might think paint your life
though has some of the best artists
going and if you want to give a truly
meaningful gift you've got to try it out
paintyourlife.com
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo at a
truly
affordable price you choose choose
rather from a team of world-class
artists
you work with them until every detail is
perfect
is a quick and easy process it's
fabulous i absolutely love
these guys i've i've used them before
their work is
top-notch it's unbelievable you get a
photo of a friend of a relative a
special place of a pet
whatever or you can combine photos it's
meaningful it's personal it can be
cherished forever
and it just looks really good it's
important for people to have
good art on their walls at
paintyourlife.com there is no risk if
you don't love the final painting your
money is refunded guaranteed
right now is a limited time offer get
twenty percent off your painting twenty
percent off in free shipping
text the word michael mich ael to sixty
four thousand
that's mich ael to sixty four thousand
paint your life celebrate
the moments that matter most
aoc is outraged
rightly so someone called her a mean
name now
we've gone through on this show before
some of the mean names that politicians
have called other politicians throughout
history
john adams famously said of alexander
hamilton
that there were not enough [ __ ] in
philadelphia to contain his secretions
that and by the way those two guys were
in the same political party right so
politics
has always been nasty aoc says she's a
big strong woman
she's very tough she can handle this she
can go toe-to-toe with any man and then
she gives this whiny uh floor address at
the house of representatives that sets
women back at least what
300 years i don't know so
the issue i don't think she's really
offended i think she's putting on a
histrionic show
and what it comes down to is a matter of
pride self-obsession
what she's so shocked by is that someone
would speak that way
to a member of congress
these are the words that representative
yoho
levied against a congresswoman
the congresswoman that not only
represents new york's 14th congressional
district
but every congresswoman and every woman
in this country
because all of us have had to deal with
this
in some form some way some shape
at some point in our lives so you see
aoc is really a stand-in for every other
woman in congress it's not about aoc
whether or not
this fellow congressman actually said
this about her it's not about aoc it's
about every single woman because aoc is
the embodiment of every woman
and he said it to a congresswoman oh my
gosh
look i like some congressmen
some congressmen or friends of mine i
sound like i'm this is like you know
look some of my best friends are black
look some of my best friends are
congresswoman okay
but this we're not talking about
like the emperor of the west we're not
talking about some high-ranking prelate
or something you're a congressman okay
congress doesn't have a great reputation
among politicians
even they're considered a little bit on
the less popular less favorable
end of things get over yourself
there's over 400 of you for goodness
sakes just get over yourself get over it
there's so many people
who go to washington to be a congressman
they don't want to do anything they just
want to be a congressman
and maybe that's what we can hope for
from aoc because if she actually
accomplishes the things she
said she says that she wants to
accomplish that would be very very bad
for the country she extrapolates from
herself to all women and then she goes
from
all women to describing this pervasive
toxic culture and that's when we start
to see
that this issue is not about one
incident
it is cultural it is a culture of lack
of impunity
of accepting of violence and violent
language
against women an entire structure of
power
that supports that so this congressman
who called a fellow congressman a mean
word apparently is now
basically doing the same thing as if he
beat his wife
she's saying he's inflicting violence on
women
she is a little confusing because she
doesn't know how to use the words that
were written for her so she says this
culture
of the lack of impunity and
because she doesn't know what the word
impunity means and probably shouldn't
have said lack of before that
but she's creating this histrionic
performance
that she is the martyr a guy says a mean
word to her on capitol hill
and therefore it's basically like she's
a
beaten battered housewife crazy right
nobody
nobody would believe that sort of thing
i think it's very bad to say mean things
to women
the congressman she's accusing of doing
this by the way says he never said it so
i don't know
i have no reason to believe aoc she's
lied about everything else in her life
so she's probably lying about this
but you know if she did we don't like
hearing those kind of mean words about
women
but what aoc is saying here is i'm a big
strong tough politician well then you
got to act like one
but they don't want to do that they want
to play fake martyrs not just members of
congress
even i mean members of congress are
probably the least sympathetic
figures in all of american life but just
below that
you have teacher union public teachers
teacher union public teachers look there
are some wonderful teachers some of the
greatest influences in my whole life
have been teachers but i think we all
know the difference between that good
teacher who cares about the students
and the teachers union teacher who gets
all these great benefits
who gets protected by the government
who's probably not that great a teacher
and who wants privileges that nobody
else in society gets well that's what
we're seeing with this
this covid reopening or or online
learning or who knows how the schools
are going to react
there's a teacher i don't know if you
know some teachers in your life i've
seen it just on facebook and twitter
teachers saying i don't want to be a
sacrificial lamb i don't want it i don't
i don't want to go into the covid where
i only have a 99.7
chance of survival at least probably
much higher than that
even though very few studies there first
of all there are no studies that say
that the kids are going to spread this
to the teachers and it's going to be
some awful terrible thing where all the
teachers die
but there's a teacher who spoke to good
morning america she said quote
i'm so sick of being expected to be some
sort of martyr because i decided to be a
teacher
and if you give me that you knew what
you were getting into when you decided
to be a teacher
crap i've got a whole host of things to
say to you none of which you're going to
like
now i'm just expected to risk my life
getting covet because of the
government's failure to act on this
pandemic i don't
think so this isn't my fault it's not
the teacher's fault
this was a young woman by the way who
statistically has a zero percent chance
of dying of the coronavirus
she is pretending to be the martyr here
right meanwhile she's inflicting
she's pretending to be receiving harm
by this coronavirus even though no
evidence of that and she is inflicting
real harm on america's students because
american students are just expected
not to have an education or to stay at
home where actually the spread of
coronavirus
might be worse based on some studies but
speaking of studies the cdc
pretty clear here says quote the best
available evidence from countries that
have opened schools indicates the covet
19 poses
low risks to school-aged children at
least in areas with low community
transmission
and suggests the children are unlikely
to be major
drivers of the spread of the virus we've
seen studies
out of finland and sweden sweden which
famously didn't even shut down of the
school-age children
based on contact racing they're not
spreading it to each other they're not
spreading it to teachers and then
they're not spreading it to their
families when they get home
why is that i don't know but as long as
we're
supposedly deferring to the science
everywhere then i think we need to at
least accept
that the cdc is the public health body
in the united states and we've got to
accept the few studies that we do have
if if we're going to play by the left's
rules of you've got to listen to the
science or we play by the rights rules
and actually have an authentic politics
of debate
and weighing priorities and having
ethical discussion either way though
reopen the schools there's no question
that that's what we ought to do
but some some teachers don't want to do
that they they just want to pretend to
be
the victims the victims are inflicting
harm the fake martyrs are in
inflicting harm in some cases this is
literal or or
i guess tangible very visible in videos
that go all around the internet there
was a woman
that went viral because
she was she became so hysterical at the
thought of a couple having a picnic
outdoors that she decided to physically
attack them
and pretend that she was playing defense
we'll get to that in a second first
though
gotta thank our friends over at keeps
you know i love my hair
i derive approximately 83 of
all of my power from my hair
but did you know that two out of three
guys will experience some form of male
pattern baldness by the time they're 35
the best way to prevent hair loss
is to do something about it while you
still have hair left you used to have to
go to the doctor's office for your hair
loss prescription now
thanks to keeps you can visit a doctor
online get your hair loss medication
delivered
right to your home they make it easy
they deliver your medication every three
months
so that you can say goodbye to pharmacy
checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits the key here is prevention
it's pretty easy
to keep your hair if you still got it so
you got to start soon
and keep treatments can take up to four
to six months or more to see results so
you gotta act fast
the sooner you start using keeps the
more hair you will save they've got
more five-star reviews than any of their
competitors nearly a hundred thousand
men trust keeps for their
hair loss prevention medication you can
get started just 10 bucks a month for a
limited time each first month free
uh really really important to do that
now especially these days if you are
ready to take action and prevent hair
loss go to keeps.com
slash knowles canon wles get your first
month of treatment for free keps.com
knowles so this lady
this was on thursday uh a lady sees a
young couple in a picnic
having a picnic in a park in san diego
so they're they're having a picnic but
they don't have masks on why don't they
have masks on
well for one they're eating and you
can't eat through a mask
for another reason they're far away from
other people they're outdoors the sun is
shining
this woman she doesn't care she don't
want to hear it this woman
walks up to them and sprays them with
mace
take a listen
you can see this is just after she's
sprayed them with mace
the guy's trying to get her away now
what are you doing
you cannot be serious you just
you just amazed him you just
faced him you just missed him you just
made
him and their food because you disagree
don't worry i'm videotaping
don't worry
what's wrong with you lady that is wrong
i think this is what we're seeing in our
culture a lot today you're seeing
the encounter of delusion
with reality and people are because
they're confusing
on the left the delusion for the reality
they're reacting in in real ways
and the rest of us are left shocked that
sounds a little abstract i'll make it a
little more concrete
this nothing is going to happen to the
crazy lady because a couple is having a
picnic
because of coronavirus it's not the
coronavirus is not going to leap from
their food
fly across the park and jump on this
lady and attack her
even if it did she has a 99.7 chance of
survival
at least at least and she's wearing her
mask
the allegedly magical mask that keeps
the coronavirus away
she should have a zero percent chance of
getting this
but because of the frenzy that people
have been whipped up into
by the mainstream media by the left by
the scientific establishment by the
politicians
because it's an election year because of
this frenzy that people are living
because of blm because of all the
nuttiness that's going on
this woman honestly believed that the
only thing that
that was an appropriate response for
this was to approach the people
further exposing her to the allegedly
super duper scary virus
and spray them in the eyes with mace
that's just a little bit of violence
that's just a tiny bit of violence
blm around the country is showing you
much more significant violence
and it's very sad it's very sad
even when the rioters get killed
you think people are happy because
rioters are getting killed i don't think
so
nobody wants to see any americans
getting gunned down in the streets
right that's a bad situation and it's a
bad situation that is caused by blm
and by the civil authorities permitting
anarchists
to riot and take over our streets it's
this encounter between
delusion and reality the delusion the
lie that's being told
that there are there's an epidemic of
racist cops slaughtering
unarmed innocent black men around the
country not true complete lie not a
not one iota of that is true
and then you've got the people reacting
to that reacting to that delusion
by coming out taking to the streets
sometimes in pretty
aggressive ways a blm rider was killed
over the weekend
how and why was he killed well he showed
up to
one of these riots they're still
happening around the country where
people are shutting down major
intersections
mobbing up on cars right coming up and
attacking people
he shows up to one of these with an
ak-47
not even an ar-15 some people don't know
the difference between these things the
ar-15 is based
off of western rifles
and the ak-47 is based off of like
soviet rifles that you see more
in the middle east and in in russia
she's got that's the one with that kind
of bendy magazine in it
so the he shows up with this ak-47
then a group of people including him
mob a car and start attacking the car
and then some bullets ring out and it is
being disputed who fired first and what
exactly happened
take a listen
you see people just totally taking over
the street walking everywhere
i can't really see quite where those
bullets are coming from
cameraman drops to the floor
[Music]
let's back up you see some more there's
more in exchange of fire
where are we where are we is
are we in fallujah are we living in the
middle east or something
why is this happening on our streets why
even before the bullets rang out why are
hordes of people allowed
to shut down whole streets and
intersections
in the first place why is that being
permitted and what what exactly happened
here
well we can at least see from
photographs
that there's a mob of people
that starts mobbing up on a car starts
banging on the car starts attacking the
car
and this guy garrett foster
has the ak-47 and he's got it pointed at
the car now it's being disputed was he
pointing it at the driver in the car or
just at the car
i think that's a little besides the
point here
then the driver in the car i guess had a
gun on him as well
and the question is who fired first and
who returned fire
the family of garrett foster are saying
that
he did not fire first at all he he did
not discharge his weapon
there was a police press conference last
night
that said that the according to the
driver
the gunman garrett foster pointed the
gun
at him in his car and so he discharged
his gun pulled away and then another
protester
fired who really knows here's what i
know
if a driver is in a car and he's got a
gun because it's texas
and you know and if this by the way were
earlier america people would be armed
much more regular than they are than
they are today
the left now wants to disarm everybody
particularly the guns that garrett
foster was using
but because the narrative is flipped now
because it's politically convenient for
them to support this guy with the gun
all of a sudden they've dropped all of
their gun control arguments
we know that there was a guy in a car
with a gun we know that there was a
mob of anarchists that had been taking
over our streets
for the last many weeks we know that one
of these rioters
had an ak-47 and it was not
just strapped behind him or something
like that we've seen him
holding the gun and it was pointed
somewhere in the vicinity
of this driver at the car maybe not
quite at the driver
but somewhere there if you are in that
situation
and you've got a mob attacking your car
and one of those guys
has an ak-47 and that ak-47 is pointed
at your car
you are one thousand percent
within your rights to defend yourself
to defend your property for one but also
to defend yourself
because guess what's going to happen if
they get you out of that car
nothing good nothing good is going to
happen driver
from every piece of evidence that we
have right now completely justified in
fact
we even have the media gaslighting on
this is so outrageous
that they're trying to cover up these
videos we have video of the guy of the
the demonstrator was killed discussing
why he brought the ak-47
in graphic us a little bit about the
language again
oh it's uh ak-47 uh where'd you got it
out tonight
they don't let us march in the streets
anymore so gotta practice some
some of all right
i think all the people that hate us and
you know want to say to us
[Music]
he's got the gun strapped across his
front not a gross back he's got it
strapped across his front
and he says yeah i've got this out here
because i think the people that want to
stop
us from taking over the streets and
bullying and intimidating them
and and disobeying the law i think the
people who want to stop us
they're two big wusses i'll say what's
this he used a more colorful word
wusses to actually do anything about it
this is aggressive language
this is threatening language and of
course he's got a
mask over his face ostensibly for kovid
although you know
all of the antifa guys have had masks
over their face forever
and he's got the ak in front of him
it's not a good situation to be in and
by the way the people who are
encouraging these riots
are in part culpable for this guy's
death
he look he's don't take your guns to
town son leave your guns at home boy
don't take your guns to town
is some age-old advice in american life
but if you're going to go there you're
going to have it out you're going to be
in a provocative situation
and you're going to be with a group
that's attacking a car and you're going
to maybe have appointed
at the car and then you're putting
yourself in an impossible situation
that's not the the narrative that the
media are going to push to you they're
going to throw out everything they've
ever believed about guns
and police and protesting rather
but it just imagine for a second i guess
this is this is how you can tell
what the real story is imagine that that
guy garrett foster were a member of the
tea party
it's impossible too because the tea
party was the best behaved political
movement
probably in the history of our country
but imagine that guy were in the tea
party
and you had a tea party guy show up with
an ar-15
and he's out there and they're mobbing
cars and let's say it were cars of
democrats you know or people of color
or women i don't know whatever whatever
you know
identity group the left is going to use
and then that person defended themselves
do you really think the media would be
would be upset about that
no they would be they would be
celebrating that someone defended
themselves against these
presumably racist terrible no-good awful
they're like
nazis in the streets these protesters
that's what you would hear
if it were the tea party but because
it's the left they throw everything
everything out of the window in fact
they call it a kid you not i've got
abc news right here they call it mostly
peaceful
which you'll get to in one second but
first i've got to thank our friends over
at rock auto
you know it can be very frustrating when
you've got to fix something
on your car and you can't get the right
part
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers so
me i don't know anything about cars some
of my friends do work on cars
which like that's nice that's a real
real benefit but i myself i don't know
anything so if i go into
the brick-and-mortar car parts store i'm
going to get ripped off they're going to
first of all they're not going to have
the part then they're going to go online
they're going to probably go to
rockauto.com order it and charge me
twice as much the rockauto.com catalog
is unique it is so easy to navigate
that even i can do it you can quickly
see all the parts available
for your vehicle and choose the brand
specifications and prices
that you want and always always reliably
low prices family run business head on
over to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
or truck and then most importantly of
all write knowles k
wlas in their how did you hear about us
box so they know that we
sent you
so there have been we're not just
talking about
one city or however many there this is
going on
all over the country and abc news
does not want you to think about the
bullets that are flying the buildings
that are being lit on fire the people
being killed
the looters the statues top they want
you to hear about
the peaceful protesters even when even
within the same sentence
that they're reporting on violence so
this was a tweet from abc news
protesters in california set fire to a
courthouse
damaged a police station and assaulted
officers
after a peaceful demonstration
intensified
in the face of that i i
lose my capacity to speak the english
language if that
is how the language will be used today i
can't i guess we don't speak the same
language
for one protesters don't set fire to
right a pr courthouses protester is a
kind of modal description
it depends what you're doing that
qualifies you as a protester so for
instance
if you're protesting then you're a
protester
when i go out and i protest i'm i'm
protesting
when i'm when i go to the beach and i
lie down in a chair i'm a sunbather
right those descriptions are based on
what i'm doing at the time
when when i'm setting a courthouse on
fire i cease to be a protester but then
this is the kicker
when a peaceful demonstration
intensifies
that means it becomes more of what it is
so if a peaceful demonstration
intensifies
it's going to become more peaceful
if if my guitar solo that i'm playing
intensifies then i'm going to be playing
like more of a guitar solo you know it's
going to be faster it's going to be
really
hotter right if if i'm
having some ice cream some sweet vanilla
ice cream
and the flavor intensifies well that
means it's going to become more vanilla
more sweet more of the ice cream when a
peaceful demonstration intensifies it
does not become violent that's that's
what happens
when it becomes its opposite when it
reverses course but something tells me
something tells me
it was never a peaceful demonstration in
the first place this is just
gas lighting it's outright denial and
this is what you see
from major politicians our friend
flekus austin fletcher somehow managed
to meet up with democratic rep jerry
nadler on the street
presents all of this evidence to him
bullets ringing out across the country
masked bandits attacking people
attacking cars looting stores
pulling down statues he says what do you
have to say about this what do you have
to say about antifa
the organized group that has its own
flag that has its own logo what do you
have to say about that
jerry like so many other people will
deny it we'll get to that in one second
first though
gotta thank you thank you for heading on
over and subscribing to the michael
knowles show youtube channel appreciate
it
be sure to hit that bell check out all
of the exclusive content posted on that
channel
and go get a reader's pass one dollar
for your first month
three dollars a month after that it's
great you get everything access to our
mobile app
articles ad free exclusive editorials
you get so much
just sign up for a buck and then three
dollars
per month after that go to dailywire.com
we'll be right back with a whole lot
more
i don't know who set up this meeting but
you've got fleckess
who's he's pretty big guy meeting up
with jerry nadler and jerry nadler's a
more
petite in the height department and
so this is kind of a funny look to begin
with
flekus presents to congressman nadler
you know all the evidence about antifa
what does nadler have to say what are
they going to do about antifa
he denies it exists it is true there's
violence across the whole country do you
just about that
from antifa that's happening in portland
right now that's right
that's a myth that's being spread only
in washington d.c
about antifa in portland yes sir there's
videos everywhere online there's fires
and riots they're
throwing fireworks at uh federal
officers dhs is there
look online it gets crazy mr nadler
it is crazy i love fleckis's attitude
he's just saying it's like
because flekas looks a little bit like a
left winger you know he's got the beard
and everything he's
got he wears shorts a lot so left
wingers are more likely to talk to him
and then he comes up and he just
spits facts at them and they run away as
jerry nadler did there
why does he deny this
as he denies this you can't deny the
everyone's seen the photos and i'm i'm
certain
that people on capitol hill have seen
the photos and the videos all over the
country
the democrats are denying this because
antifa is the military wing of the
democratic party
that's it that's the only explanation
don't you think that you
if there were violence going on in the
streets
and this had no association with you and
you did not benefit from that violence
that you would denounce it or try to
stop it i mean you know the left always
says of the right
of the republicans that you know that
we've we've got these neo-nazis and
white supremacists who are really
pervasive and violent which is not true
they're like four of
them in the entire country but every
time you hear one of these incidents of
some
neo-nazis or something republicans
denounce it immediately
try to put a stop to it the left does
not do that with antifa
which is which is much more pervasive in
committing much more violence
why because antifa is the military wing
of the democratic party i was i'm
looking around all
of this by the way is because of the
election the blm stuff it's not because
of george floyd it's because of the
election
the covid lockdowns we got to stay
locked down forever it's not because of
the scientific
establishment because of scientific
papers the scientific papers say to
reopen the schools right or
see a scientific paper can't say that
but a scientific organization like the
cdc
reading scientific papers from finland
and sweden and other places says reopen
the schools doesn't matter
nothing about the current coveted
response has anything to do with covid
or any virus or anything like that
that's to do with the election and i
thought
is this just what election year is going
to be like from now on are we so at each
other's throats
don't forget we've had these tough
really tight elections at least
for 20 years now at least since bush v
gore
where they didn't want to give up the
white house then is
are we just gonna have violence in the
streets and shooting in the streets now
every
every four years because the left can't
handle the fact that they're losing
elections
is that what's going to happen i hope
not
but it seems like we might be getting
that because
we're just getting excuses for violence
and the the people who are pretending to
be the aggrieved victims here
very often are the ones inflicting much
more harm on others
for instance a complete degenerate
by the name of isaiah jackson
just photographed himself kneeling
on a two-year-old child's neck isaiah
jackson is a 20 year old black guy
the child is a white two-year-old
wearing a diaper
being held down by another arm in the
photo we don't know
who that arm belongs to i think it
belongs to a woman
and he's shirtless he's throwing
some kind of sign down there child is
crying and it says
b-l-m now m-f
you look at this fight it's really a
heinous photo
fortunately this guy has been arrested
though he was arrested for a probation
violation
this you know this wonderful peaceful
demonstrator peaceful protester
ex-con degenerate who should never
ever ever be permitted out of prison at
least
at least never ever this guy
posts a photo as he is
violently attacking a two-year-old child
and in that photo he pretends to be the
victim
the photo which is very difficult to
look at is emblematic
of the whole damn culture
the violent aggressor pretends to be
the victim that's what's happening
that's what's happening right now blm
now
mother effer as a two-year-old child
cries
fortunately in the case of this guy he's
been arrested and i hope he he never
sees the light of day again
hope he hope he's gonna be in that
prison cell maybe i don't know maybe
ship him to gitmo or something i don't
know
no civil punishment could be too extreme
for this guy
but he's just one guy how about all the
other people who've shut down our
our city streets for the past several
weeks attacked
public property attacked people ruined
businesses ruined lives
burned things down burned down our
country what about that
why are we inflicting this harm on our
self
it's like a form of neurosis
it's like a form of self-mutilation that
we're doing to ourselves as a country
and we're not willing to heal up the
wounds now finally finally at least
there's a little bit of evidence that
the civil authority is going to do
something
dhs department of homeland security is
finally going into portland and
arresting some of these organized
anarchists
and the left is throwing a hissy fit
about that and they're just lying by the
way
you know i was debating this guy this
some guy from the young turks hassan
[ __ ]
we were on a local fox show here and uh
he
he was giving i don't think he was lying
in that i don't think he knew he was
saying things that are not true he was
just repeating boilerplate leftist
talking points
that just were that are just
demonstrably false
so he said un uniformed federal
agents are going into portland that's
not true
all of the dhs officers going into
portland have uniforms on
there it doesn't say who they are with
yes it does it says dhs right on their
uniforms
well it doesn't say who the officers are
yes it does it's got their officer id
numbers right above
dhs on their uniforms well they have no
right to go into portland actually
the whole reason dhs was founded
one of the main reasons it was founded
at the very least was to protect federal
property and federal courthouses being
attacked
well okay but they don't have any right
to leave the federal grounds and pursue
criminals
on the city streets actually they do
it's very clear that they do it's in the
u.s code
they're doing they are doing exactly
what they were set up
to do but now when you enforce the law
in any way
that is considered lawless by the left
and when you engage in a lawlessness
that is considered the height of justice
under the law
consider the new york times consider the
new york times
blm always has to be right you know that
the leftist narrative always has to be
right and good
they're the martyrs no matter what no
matter what the evidence no matter what
photos we see
with little crying two-year-old children
no matter what videos we see
they've got to be in the right new york
times tweets this out
to understand what's wrong with our
public education system you have to look
at what's arguably the most powerful
force in our schools
white parents listen to the trailer for
nice white parents a new series from
serial brought to you from the new york
times
brought to you by the new york times
yeah those white people they're terrible
huh
they're true this was my response i
tweeted that one when the time sent this
out i said
yeah white people are terrible i hate
those white people so much they're so
much worse than all the other people
because all those other people are
better than the white people because
their skin is a different color
hashtag anti-racism
now this is theoretically kind of
humorous right because
it's very racist what the new york times
said but
not according to the new york times's
own logic
actually according to the new york
times's logic this is anti-racist
because according to the new york times
according to the left broadly
all white people are racist they say
this openly there are best-selling books
about this right now
you will very likely have to go into
some corporate training seminar
about how all white people are racist
and
more than that all racists are white
people
there's no such thing as a black racist
there can't be even when nick cannon
says that white people are savages and
less than human and don't have souls
that's not racist because you can't be
racist against white people
according to the left that's what they
say they teach this openly at
universities
and in corporate training sessions so
people look at this they say well new
york times that is that's just
anti-white that is an anti-racist
but for the left it is by definition the
same thing
obviously that is redefining words
beyond anything even close
to what they actually convey
but that's where we are the
the people decrying racism the worst
inflictors of racism themselves the fake
martyrs
inflicting more harm than anybody else
that we see out there
it's the this is the same insane logic
on the virus whatever the left
says at any given time must be true
even if it's immediately contradicted
i was thinking when i was debating that
young turks guy
he said well look you know the virus is
spreading a lot and we need the masks
i said right but there's no evidence
that the masks do anything i said no no
there is that's what the scientists say
today i said right but
i've got a study we read it on the show
last week i've got a study
it's not actually not just one study
it's 14 different studies
actual clinical studies controlled
studies
on the cdc website that was posted what
like eight weeks ago or something seven
eight weeks ago
that says the masks don't do anything he
said oh no but that was them that was
that was 78 weeks ago now that
scientists say that it does something
even though there are no studies about
that whatsoever but you realize there's
a problem there
if the scientists were wrong just two
months ago
why do we think they're right now or
worse
as we saw with the masks when when all
the public officials said don't wear
masks masks don't work
and then they turned around immediately
say you have to wear a mask
we are told oh well they were only
saying that the first time to lie to us
so they could keep the masks for the
healthcare workers well if they were
lying to us then
why do we assume they're not lying to us
now why do why do we believe them now
there's this problem
of credibility and you saw this
on opening day for the washington
nationals
so they decide the nats decide
to get dr fauci 79 years old actually
looks pretty good for 79
to throw out the opening pitch this is
probably not going to go
so great take a listen
to the stadium he's there he's got the
mask on it goes
basically in between home plate and the
first first base
you can't hear anything at the stadium
because there's nobody in the stadium
it's a little bit of a set up there
because no one's allowed in and dr
fauci in this empty baseball stadium 60
feet away from anybody
on the pitcher's mound is wearing the
stupid mask
he's not going to get grown up he's very
socially distant he's 10 times
socially distanced but he's got the mask
on
and then later when he thinks the
cameras are off
he's sitting in the stands it's just him
and two friends of his they're the only
people in the stands they get their
private baseball game
nobody else does and fauci takes his
mask off
his mask is below his mouth and his nose
he's not eating anything he's not
drinking anything he just doesn't want
to wear the mask makes sense i don't
want to wear the mask either
and i don't very rarely do i wear the
mask
there's no way that dr fauci thought
that he was at risk of getting
coronavirus on the pitcher's bound
but was not at risk of getting
coronavirus when he's six inches away
from his two friends
sitting in the stands he just isn't
worried about getting the coronavirus
and he's
not actually it of the belief that the
masks are going to stop it
i don't think dr fauci's opinion has
changed one little bit
i think that if you want to know what
somebody really believes
and you can either listen to what he
says or look at what he does look at
what he does
that will tell you much more about what
that person actually
believes i don't think
anybody has changed their mind on the
masks at all i think it is a placebo
for the society to feel better about
everything but what it's really doing
the effect of it
is not to calm everybody down that's
been the pitch for the masks we're the
masks
then we can all go back to work and
it'll calm everybody down it won't the
point of the masks
the the actual effect of them is to get
everybody super nervous and to look
around at all their fellow citizens
like they're walking cesspools of germs
and to keep
a lid on this economy and we can't do
that forever you know the the
federal government right now is talking
about a new stimulus
for the coronavirus lockdown you
remember we have already
spent six trillion dollars on this to
get us through four months and it
by the way that stimulus didn't really
get us through those four months
six trillion so that means if we
extrapolate that over a year that's
going to be at least 18 trillion dollars
and if we spend 18 trillion dollars at
the way gdp is currently trending that's
more money than we will produce
all year the whole country if we took
everybody's wealth that they they create
this year
we still wouldn't have enough money to
pay out a
year-long federal coronavirus subsidy
so uh treasury secretary steve mnuchin
uh met with gop staffers they're trying
to arrange some new
stimulus they probably do need this one
is a political tool just to get through
the election
but also because people are really
hurting and the government said you
can't go to work so they get you got to
do something if the government's going
to shut you down
government's got to help you out the
issue with the last one which was
designed to keep the country
locked down through november that's why
the democrats pushed for it
the problem with the last one is it paid
people more on unemployment
than they would get otherwise from their
jobs two-thirds of people according to a
cato instituted study
got more than 100 of their paycheck on
the unemployment benefit
two-thirds one-third of people got twice
as much as
they were making on their unemployment
benefit
so that doesn't make sense the federal
government steven mnuchin is trying to
lower that down
to making about 70 of what you were
making
on your salary that seems about right to
me
you need to incentivize people to go
back to work you need to incentivize
businesses to reopen
unfortunately there's this political
battle going on where local governments
don't want to reopen and the federal
government does
so the federal government is using
what's at their disposal to do this
by the way if the states want to keep
you locked down then they should make up
the difference
if it's 70 and you want to make 100 the
states that are
forcing you to lock down should be
required to make up
that difference now fortunately though
somebody is making some money
in all of this and that would be
nicholas sandman do you remember him
he's the covington school kid
he's the he was catholic school kid who
showed up for the march for life he was
standing at the national mall
by our monuments before the left was
defacing all of our monuments
and he's standing there in a maga hat
and some group of black supremacists
called the hebrew israelites
were screaming all sorts of terrible
things of the kids and then some native
american lunatic guy
old man walks up and starts banging a
drum in this kid's face and the kid was
very composed and he was smeared by the
mainstream media
as a racist as an instigator is all
these sorts of terrible things
so that kid did not take it lying down
he sued he sued
cnn for 250 million he sued washington
post for 250 million
he's got six more outstanding lawsuits
they already settled with cnn cnn
already paid this kid out
washington post just settled with him
too i hope this kid makes a mint
i hope this kid makes several hundred
thousand dollars several hundred million
dollars rather
six more to go
the whole problem with the covington
story was
a confusion of who was the victim and
who was the aggressor
in the in what actually happened
unfortunately other people had cameras
around so we got to see
the real story that doesn't always
happen the real story was
that the kid was just standing there
minding his own business
and the black supremacists and that
native american with the drum were the
aggressors
that was the real story and yet what we
were told is
the native american man was the martyr
and nick sandman was the oppressor
they smeared this kid ruined his life in
a culture such as ours
in a culture such as ours you've got to
be skeptical of
any message of this sort that you get
i'll give you one one last example
netflix just put out this
it's not really a trailer it's just a
clip from a show
it was a woman who kind of took over not
a woman actually a man who now
identifies as a woman
is a a writer and took over the netflix
twitter account for a day
and tweeted out this episode of the
babysitter's club
depicting quote unquote a young trans
girl so the
the babysitter's club
has this it's a scene where there's a
young girl
and this girl's friend or brother or
something is in the hospital
and the person in the hospital is this
little boy who's dressed up like a girl
and the doctors and the nurses come in
and they misgender
the little boy by calling him a boy
have you been giving him fluids if he's
dehydrated we'll need to place an iv
have him change into this i don't want
the blue one
um well i hear someone's not feeling
well
let's take a look at the little man
can i please talk to you too outside
i know that you guys are busy but
as you would see if you looked at her
and not her chart
bailey is not a boy and by treating her
like one you are completely ignoring who
she is
you're making her feel insignificant and
humiliated
and that's not going to help her feel
good or safe or calm
so i'm here on now please recognize her
for who she is and if at all possible
could you find me a non-blue hospital
gown
i apologize i love the doctor so
terrified at the end
i'm sorry yes i'll go get you a hospital
gown because that's what doctors do
doctors go and get hospital gowns but
the doctor probably should be terrified
because now if you suggest that men are
not really women
and women cannot magically become men
then
you're considered a bigot you'll lose
your job you'll get doxed your family
will be attacked
so probably the the doctor is right to
be fearful
consider the message that this is
sending the person who tweeted this out
a
a writer a trans woman i mean you know a
man
and a former babysitter and
we need to talk about how wonderful this
young this episode is
and this depiction of a young trans
person what's really happening here
is that one of the largest studios in
hollywood
in the mainstream media most powerful
culture machine ever devised
is pushing this message that we need to
treat confused children confused little
boys
as if they are girls and vice versa the
implication being by the way
when a confused little boy says he's a
girl
instead of saying no you're not just
like when i said i was batman my mother
said no you're not batman
instead of trying to make the kid
come into closer accordance with reality
you indulge that delusion
and then presumably you'll pump him full
of hormones you'll
fundamentally change his sexual
development this is this is being pushed
already by the
so-called transgenderist advocates
how perverted is that how perverse is
that that you've now got an entire
culture
in which if you do not encourage little
boys
who are confused to become little girls
you're somehow the bad guy
that is some perverse stuff
that is some dark dark stuff
the the villains here are the people
who are pretending to be the wonderful
good
compassionate crowd
and the people the doctor who's just
trying to
give the little boy the treatment for
the little boy who's actually trying to
heal somebody
he's supposed to be the victim or he's
supposed to be the the villain rather in
all of this
a total inversion it's not just
happening in one area
or another it's happening in the whole
culture and if you approach
anything any of this from the mainstream
media to hollywood to the scientific
establishment the public health
establishment to the professional race
hustlers to the the
elected politicians who are who are
whining because someone called them a
mean word
in a political argument if you are
taking any of that at face value
if you were giving any of that the
benefit of the doubt then you don't see
just how upside down the culture has
become that's our show i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer
austin stevens assistant director pavel
wadowski
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva production assistant ryan
love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
20 20. you know the matte wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture because culture drives politics
and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about hope
you'll
give it a listen